Speaker 1: Let's go to Lexi from New
Mexico. Lexi, welcome to the program.
And Lexi, you've got to unmute yourself.
You've currently self muted. And only if you
turn that off will I be able to hear you.
Speaker 5: Hi, David. Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes.
Speaker 5: Sorry. I was on the process
of making sure I was completely muted on discord.
So you don't yell at me. Beautiful. Beautiful.
So I'm a young voter. I just turned 18 in
this last June, so I got to vote for the
first time. Beautiful. And something I saw, at
least here in New Mexico on my voting bases is
how active, especially the older voting group
is just first hand compared to younger voters
and like Gen Xers. Right. And then seen in my
own classroom and even then, like my parents,
friends and everything, how so many people
still have the mentality of whatever I do,
whatever I vote for. It doesn't really affect me
in politics, especially when it comes to national
politics. So many people just don't think that
their vote matters and don't really think that
anything big is going to happen. But I think the
reason we've started to see that change a little
bit more with younger voters is the Republicans
rhetoric. We're against the LGBTQ community
because so many young voters and young people are
part of that community. Yes. So they I think it's
going to be hard for Republicans going off way.
The caller a few callers ago was talking about for
Republicans to fully grab on to the younger voting
base because they are pushing that issue so hard.
Speaker 1: I tend to agree with you. I think
unless they ease up a little bit on that stuff,
they are going to struggle with the 18 to 29
year olds, but not not necessarily because 18 to
28 year olds are part of that group, but to some
degree, because 18 to 29 year olds don't see it as
logical to be attacking individuals who are LGBTQ.
Speaker 5: Yeah, because even if they're not part
of that group, a lot of them have friends
in that group or they know people in that
group and everything. So yeah, I agree. But
my question is, how do you think Democrats
can not only start to mobilize more younger
voters, but just all the people who are center
and center left who I know who just don't
go and vote? Because from my perspective,
I see that it's much more likely for the people
who are center right and right to go vote than the
people who are center left and left to go vote.
Because Democrats are just so bad at mobilizing
and motivating voters. And that will likely see.
Speaker 1: A wedge, which I think you're
absolutely right. You know, I don't have any
special insights on Get Out the vote. This is
a known issue that get out the vote is tough on 18
to 29 year olds. But I think the instinct you have
is absolutely correct. The right is pouring money
into it, as I talked about earlier with another
caller. And unless the left starts doing it and
activating people with these glitzy events and
wrestling style intros, I hate to say it, but the
right does some of that stuff because it works and
the left needs to figure out how to do it. Listen,
Lexie, I'm going to let you go because I am out of
time. I appreciate everybody who called in. We're
going to take a quick break and be right back.